[ Générique ]
Monsieur le premier ministre nous avons un problème
le nombre de morts à la guerre explose le plancher
nous craignons une disparition totale de la population d'ici jeudi.
J'ai une idée !
On va passer une loi pour interdire la mort à la guerre !
Ok !
[Générique télévisé]
Première mesure du gouvernement pour résorber la mort à la guerre
Faire semblant
Pour mieux comprendre la situation
Regardons ensemble le sujet de
Gilouk Sechelle
Depuis la mise en vigueur de cette lois
Le visage de la guerre a bien changer
Hier on pouvait voir des champs de bataille remplis de sang
De membres arrachés ou encore de viscères a même le sol
Aujourd'hui tout cela n'est qu'un lointains souvenir
(grenade)
1, 2 , 3 (bruitage explosion )
même la torture prend une meilleur tournure ...
je vais te passé a table sale fils de chien
(blblblblblblbblblblbl)
(respiration)
jamais tu entend!!!
jaimais!!!!
bruitage mitraillette
ot now
non Dany non
ici maintenant tout ce qui tache...  c'est la boue!
non c'est relou c'est relou j'en ai mare
ah ça va!?
ouais oui oui
excuse moi j'avais oublié
que chui mort
bon bin relève toi
Monsieur le premier ministre nous avons encore un problème
comme les gens ne meurs plus a la guerre!
nous connaissons une hausse démographique sans précédant
j'ai une idée
on va enterrer nos morts pour de faux ! Pour de vrai !
Ok !
Ok, heum ! Je suis pas vraiment décédé
J'y peut rien, c'est les ordres
Heuuuu ! Je suis pas mort en fait !
Générique de fin